Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
You can call anytime you want. I got a
great voicemail from a very nice older lady,
she says. She's an older lady. She wants me to
know. The older folks aren't all wacky conspiracy
theory spreading Trumpists. She also praises
my occasional pronunciation of the animal dog.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hi, David, this is Darcy.
Thank you for recently gracing us with the
correct pronunciation of the word dog. Anyway,
I'm going to see if you can give a shout out
to for some validation to your listeners. Yes,
we are not all science tonight. Your snack
watching Trumpists as portrayed in popular
media. Thank you for clearly presenting facts
and knowledge. Keep up the good fight to.
Speaker 1: Absolutely, Miss Darcy is completely
correct. We have listeners that I know of
progressive listeners into their 90s, and that's
a fantastic thing when we say statistically
the disinformation is coming from 65 plus or when
we say statistically on Facebook, it's older folks
reshare. Just because we make a statistical
statement doesn't mean I would wrongly think
that of every one of our older viewers. No doubt
about it, and I appreciate the clarification.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
What actually came from the U.N. climate
summit? What happened there? We're going to talk
about it. We will talk about a bipartisan bill
that would force Big Tech to offer algorithm free
feeds and search results. We used to have this.
You used to be able to just see your Twitter
feed in reverse chronological order. No
algorithmic elements at all. We're going
to talk about that. And then lastly,
things are not looking good in Germany from the
standpoint of COVID. And this could be what's
coming for the United States. I know, I know.
It's like, we're again. We're doing it again.
It's not looking good in Germany. I'm going to
talk about that. My brother actually just landed
in Germany this morning for work, and let's
just say he made sure to get his third dose
before going over there. So all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. Sign up at join
Packman dot com. You'll get instant access.
And I look forward to you joining me this.